hi my name is Sandeep a developer
advocate on the Google cloud platform
welcome to the Google Data Center at The
Dalles Oregon take a look around before
we go inside we need to make sure that
we have the appropriate security
clearance most Google employees can't
even get in here
so let's go on a special
behind-the-scenes tour I'm here with
Noah from the site reliability
engineering team Noah you tell us a
little bit more about the sre role at
Google yeah Esther is write and maintain
the software systems designed to keep
our services running so what happens if
one of these systems goes down we've
designed our systems from the ground up
to be able to handle any unexpected
failures that might occur we have highly
redundant power networking and serving
domains so even if we do lose an entire
cluster we're able to redirect those
workloads and live migrate data in order
to minimize any impact in addition we
have a team of sres on call 24/7 that
can tackle any problems that might arise
thanks Noah so now we learn more about
the systems that manage our fleet at
Google let's take a deeper look at the
data center infrastructure itself
welcome inside before we can continue
further we need to go through the
biometric ire scan and circle lock these
only allow one person at a time and
require dual authentication to continue
further I'll see you on the other side
welcome to the data center floor as you
can tell we have a lot of servers and
this is a single cluster in a single
floor in a single building managing all
of these servers on global scale is
quite a challenge to utilize our fleet
we use tools such as port Colossus and
spanner you may be familiar with similar
tools such as kubernetes
Google Cloud storage and bigquery at
these tools a lot of Google engineers
and cloud customers more easily manage
infrastructure allowing everyone to both
innovative and scalable applications
here at Google a longer infrastructure
is custom-made this gives us the
flexibility and the principles abstract
things seems to be a common theme here
at Google I've also those have a lot of
fiber running in our data centers that's
right
single building can support seventy five
thousand machines and carry over one cut
event per second of bandwidth actually
more than the entire Internet this
allows us access resources so how is
this nice I finally know what all this
Google Fiber is really used for thanks
Virginia no problem
so now you've seen all the compute and
networking horsepower required to run
your workloads in the cloud let's take a
look at where your data is safely and
securely stored
[Music]
whether you're querying terabytes of
data on bigquery or storing petabytes of
Google Cloud storage all of your data
needs to be stored on a physical device
our data center infrastructure allows us
to access our storage quickly and
securely on our scale we need to handle
hard drive and SSD failure on a daily
basis while your data is replicated and
safe we need to destroy or recycle used
hard drives so no one can access your
data from the time that disk is removed
from the server to the time its
decommission we maintain a very strict
chain of custody but this are completely
wiped and then destroyed in a huge
shredder
let's go shred some hard drives
[Music]
we've looked at a lot of the hardware
that runs in our data centers but it
doesn't end there
we need to cool and power our
infrastructure and an environmentally
sustainable and reliable way let's take
a look at how we cool our servers
welcome to the mechanical equipment room
looks pretty cool doesn't it okay it's
Brian one of our data center facilities
technicians hey Brian Frankie tell us a
little bit more about this room
sure well this is a cooling plan but one
of the data centers that we have on-site
so a lot of heat is generated on the
server floor and it all has to be
removed and that starts right here in
the cooling plant so it's basically
Toulouse we have the condenser water
loop and we have the process water loop
the process water loop are these blue
and red pipes over here so they take the
heat off the server floor and they
transfer it to these heat exchangers
here the condenser water loop are these
green and yellow pipes here they take
the cold water from the base and
underneath it they transfer it to the
ec8 exchangers here and they send it up
to the cooling towers up on the roof and
notice our pipes are Google colors it's
pretty cool so how efficient is our data
center well Google has some of the most
efficient data centers in the world in
fact when we started reporting our power
usage effectiveness or PUA in 2008 most
other data centers were around 100
percent overhead at that point in time
Google was 20% overhead but since then
we reduce it to just 12% and that even
includes our cafeterias whoa that is so
low also what's this big green machine
for oh well this is a chiller you very
rarely use them but it helped keep the
process water temperature in the desired
temperature range when it gets really
hot outside basically helping the
cooling tower do its job and some of our
newer data centers they have no chillers
at all I love how our new data centers
are even more efficient by the way can
we go up and take a look at a cooling
tower sure let's go
Wow
what a view up here so Cindy this is a
cooling tower it uses evaporation to
rapidly cool the water from the
condenser loop and sends it back down to
the basin you could say we're making
actual clouds with the cloud clouds
making actual clouds welcome to Google
so Brian how do we power the cloud well
that all starts with Google's power
substation let's go take a look so this
is the Google own power substation this
is where the high voltage power enters
the site it's reduced and then sent to
multiple power distribution centers such
as this one right here what happens if a
Power Distribution Center loses power if
it loses power we have multiple
generator and utility backup sources
available to maintain power to those
servers and where does all the power
come from it actually comes from
multiple hydroelectric power plants that
are nearby
I love how Google uses reliable green
energy whenever possible we are 100%
carbon neutral actually that's pretty
cool you know it seems like Google
builds reliability from the ground up
from the power and cooling all the way
to the software systems that manage our
fleet
thanks for showing me around Brian no
problem never great Dan thank you for
joining me on this special
behind-the-scenes tour please check out
cloud Google comm to learn how you can
build what's next